GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME BACK TO
BUDGET SUB FOR WE GOT A VERY
SHORT CALENDAR.
I JUST WANT TO BE HEARD AND A
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR SO TO GET
THE BALL ROLLING.
FIRST WE HAVE LOCAL THE STYLISH
CORN PLEASE.
COOPER HERE
GONNA SECOND -- ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI.
TWO LACKEY.
THE VARIANT.
WICKS HI. FOR MOST NUMBER TO
VOTE EARLY ISSUES ONE TEN AND
ELEVEN THEIR MOTION.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
UBER HI [inaudible]
TWO LACKEY THOUGH.
THIS VARIANT WICKS.
EMOTIONS WERE THREE VOTE ONLY
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWELVE SEC ROLL CALL PLEASE
COOPER HI.
TO LACKEY VOTING.
IS THERE IN [inaudible]
WICKS.
WHICH SIX THE STORE ONLY ON TO
BE HEARD -- ISSUE NUMBER ONE
HOUSING FIRST PEARLY PROGRAMS
THING UP
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
GINNY PUDDY FOOT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL.
AND WITH ME IS STEPHANIE WELCH
WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COUNCIL
AND STEPHANIE IS ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL.
THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE BEFORE YOU IS THE
RESULT OF DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
HOME WAS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL.
AND WITH THE INTERAGENCY WORKING
GROUP.
WHICH HAS BEEN ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH STATE DEPARTMENTS TO ASSESS
THEIR PROGRAMS FOR COMPLIANCE
WITH HOUSING FIRST.
BY THE JULY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN STATUTORY DEADLINE.
THE PURPOSE OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS TO RECONCILE TWO
IMPORTANT POLICY GOALS.
ADDRESSING THE CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS AND ADDRESSING THE
CRISIS OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS.
WE KNOW THAT BEST PRACTICE FOR
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IS THE
ADOPTION OF HOUSING FIRST
PRINCIPLES.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT BEST PRACTICE
TO ADDRESS SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS.
IS A CONTINUUM OF TREATMENT
OPTIONS FROM DETOX AND INTENSE
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS. TO
OUTPATIENT PROGRAMS INCLUDING
THE OPTION OF LIVING IN APPEARS
SUPPORTED SOBER LIVING
ENVIRONMENT.
THE DECISION AS TO WHERE ON THE
CONTINUE OF TREATMENT OPTIONS A
PERSON SHOULD BE PLACED.
IS ONE THAT SHOULD BE MADE BY
THE INDIVIDUAL AND HIS OR HER
CLINICIAN.
CURRENTLY THE HOUSING FIRST
STATUTE DOES NOT EXPLICITLY
ADDRESS RECOVERY HOUSING WHICH
INCLUDES SOBER LIVING FACILITIES.
AND REQUIRES THE TENANT
SELECTION PROCESSES ACCEPT
APPLICANTS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
SOBRIETY YOUR USE OF ALCOHOL AND
DRUGS.
AND ALSO REQUIRES THE USE OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUGS NOT BE AN
IMMEDIATE REASON FOR EVICTION.
BY DEFINITION RECOVERY HOUSING
REQUIRES ADHERENCE TO SOBRIETY
AS A CORE COMPONENT OF TREATMENT.
IN SEEKING GUIDANCE TO RESOLVE
THIS ISSUE THE COUNCIL CONSULTED
WITH AN EXPERT IN HOMELESSNESS
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT.
AND REVIEWED POLICY GUIDANCE
FROM THE US DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT OR
HUD.
HOW TECHNOLOGY IS THE IMPORTANCE
OF BOTH HOUSING FIRST AND
RECOVERY HOUSING?
AND SUGGEST THAT IF RECOVERY
HOUSING ADOPT SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS IT CAN BE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH HOUSING FIRST
PRINCIPLES AND AN APPROPRIATE
CHOICE. FOR PEOPLE SEEKING
TREATMENT FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS.
THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS INTENDED TO
RECONCILE THESE TWO POLICY GOALS
TO ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO MAINTAIN
CHOICE ALONG WITH ENSURING.
ACCESS TO TREATMENT OPTIONS THAT
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
PRINCIPLES OF HOUSING FIRST.
IT SPECIFIES THAT RECOVERY
HOUSING MUST COMPLY WITH THE
FOLLOWING REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER
TO ALSO BE IN ALIGNMENT WITH
HOUSING FIRST. ONE UNLESS
MANDATED BY THE COURT OR
CONDITION OF PAROLE.
PARTICIPATION IN A SOBER LIVING
ENVIRONMENT MUST BE VOLUNTARY.
TWO THERE MUST BE MINIMUM
BARRIERS TO ENTRY SO THAT LONG
PERIODS OF SOBRIETY CLEAN
CRIMINAL RECORDS OR CLEAR
EVICTION HISTORIES ARE NOT
REQUIRED FOR PROGRAM ENTRY.
THREE THE PROGRAM MUST INCLUDE
RELAPSE SUPPORT THE DOES NOT
AUTOMATICALLY IF VICTOR JUST
CHARGE A PROGRAM PARTICIPANT FOR
TEMPORARY LAPSE BUT THAT ALSO
ALLOWS FOR MOVEMENT OF A
PARTICIPANT INTO A HIGHER LEVEL
OF CARE IS APPROPRIATE.
AND FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
DETERMINED THEY ARE NO LONGER
INTERESTED IN LIVING.
IN A HOUSING SETTING WITH AN
ABSTINENCE FOCUS OR WHO ARE JUST
CHARGER EVICTED FROM THE PROGRAM
MUST BE OFFERED ASSISTANCE IN
FINDING ALTERNATIVE HOUSING.
INCLUDING HOUSING WITH A HOUSING
FIRST HARM REDUCTION APPROACH.
IN OUR VIEW ADOPTION THIS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE INSURERS
THAT PROGRAMS FUNDED IMPLEMENTED
OR ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE.
CAN COMPLY WITH THE JULY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN STATUTORY
DEADLINE FOR ADOPTING HOUSING
FIRST PRINCIPLES.
AND ALSO ALLOW THE STATE TO
CONTINUE TO ADHERE TO BEST
PRACTICES FOR TREATING SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS WHILE MAINTAINING
INDIVIDUAL CHOICE.
AS TO WHETHER A SOBER LIVING
ENVIRONMENT IS THE BEST OPTION
FOR THEM IN THEIR RECOVERY.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
STEPHANIE WELCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A QUESTION FOR THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MR.
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST I KNOW
THIS ITEM IS TO BE HELD OPEN BUT
I JUST WANNA STAY MY PERSPECTIVE
ON IT.
WHICH IS PROBABLY NOT GONNA BE A
SURPRISE IS THE CHAIR OF THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE -- I BELIEVE
AND I THINK THIS LEGISLATURE
STOOD FOR THE PRINCIPLE THAT
HOUSING FIRST IS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY AND AN IN
HOMELESSNESS.
AND I SHARE THE CONCERNS THAT I
KNOW BEEN RAISED BY OTHERS THAT
THE CHANGES THAT ARE PROPOSED IN
THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
COULD AND LIKELY WILL
DISADVANTAGED THOSE AND RECOVERY
AN INCREASE HOMELESSNESS  KNOW
THAT CITY SEE OUR NEW THAT THIS
POLICY APPLIED WHEN SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE ITEMS
THAT WE DO THINK SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED IN A POLICY COMMITTEE
RATHER THAN HERE SO IF I TO VOTE
ON IT TODAY I WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT IT -- JUST WANNA SAY
THAT AS THIS CONTINUES ON IN THE
DELIBERATIONS AND THERE YOU GO.
AT MY PERSPECTIVES PROBABLY NOT
A SURPRISE.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND
BECAUSE IDEALLY WE WOULD WE
WOULD ABSOLUTELY HAVE PREFERRED
TO TAKE THIS TO THE POLICY
COMMITTEE.
ON THIS ISSUE ACTUALLY DID NOT
REALLY COME TO LIGHT UNTIL LATE
MARCH -- WHEN THE WORKING GROUP
REALLY HAS BEEN TURNING FROM ONE
DEPARTMENT TO ANOTHER IN OUR
DELIBERATIONS AND ASSISTANCE
WITH DEPARTMENTS?
AND AT THAT POINT WE WE FLAG IT
AND TOOK IT TO THE HOMELESS
COURTING IN FINANCING COUNCIL IN
OUR APRIL MEETING -- AND WE WE
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE SUFFICIENT
TIME TO BRING IT TO THE POLICY
COMMITTEE AS WE WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO TORONTO INTO THE APARTMENT NO
WHEN.
CENTER MITCHELL'S BILL PASSED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO POWER I'M GOING TO
DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT FOR THAT
I COULD COUNT APARTMENT A
FINANCE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THE DEPARTMENT WAS NOT AWARE
THAT THIS WITH BILL WITH APPLY
TO THEM AND THEREFORE THIS IS
PART OF THE REASON. FOR THE NEED
WHEN THIS ISSUE CAME UP IN LATE
MARCH BECAUSE IT COULD HAVE --
YOU KNOW POSSIBLY TO A FAX
EITHER IT'S GOING TO EFFECTIVELY
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PRO IS A
COUNTRY WITH EXISTING PROGRAMS
OR THERE WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT.
CAN -- BUDGET IMPACT TO TREAT
MORE FOLKS UNDER THE HOUSING
FIRST PRINCIPLE SO -- THEY
WEREN'T AWARE AND I THINK IT'S
AN INTERPRETATION OF THE
LANGUAGE AFTER THAT THE THE FACT
THAT'S DRIVING THE NEED FOR THIS
CHANGE WHY YES AND WE'RE STILL
LEFT WITH THE POLICY
CONVERSATIONS SO HAPPENING GAUGE
WITH.
YOU GUYS ON THIS AS THIS ITEM IS
HELD OPEN BUT JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT SO THERE'S NO SURPRISES.
THANK YOU.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS -- NUMBER ONE
IS TIME SENSITIVE.
IT IS VERY TIME SENSITIVE -- THE
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY REQUIRES THAT
STATE DEPARTMENTS COMPLY WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS OF HOUSING
FIRST.
BY JULY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND AS THE COUNCIL
WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT COMPLIANCE.
AND WHAT OTHER GROUPS WILL THIS
AFFECT.
I CAN SPEAK TO THAT -- AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT I DO
REPRESENT CDC ARE -- ON THE
COMMERCE COURT NAME FINANCING
COUNCIL AND SO I CAN -- SUPPORT
THAT -- WE WERE UNAWARE THAT ARE
TREATMENT PROGRAMS WOULD FALL
UNDERNEATH THIS PARTICULAR
COMPONENT AND INTO IT UNTIL LATE
MARCH AND SO -- BUT AT AS A ARE
MY COUNSEL ACTUALLY TRIES TO TO
ADVOCATE FOR POLICIES THAT ARE
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BOTH SUBSTANCE USE A
MENTAL ILLNESS AS WELL AS FORMER
INCARCERATION.
SO THERE ARE POTENTIALLY OTHER
STATE DEPARTMENTSIT'S NOT
NECESSARILY A CDC ARE ISSUE THAT
DO PROVIDE SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE EXITING INCARCERATION.
TO RECEIVE TREATMENT SERVICES
FOR THEIR SUBSTANCE USE NEED SO
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT OTHER
DEPARTMENTS POTENTIALLY GRANTS
THAT ARE OPERATED THROUGH THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS.
AS WELL AS SOME OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE OPERATED -- THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
MIGHT -- BE IMPACTED BY THIS IN
THAT THAT THEY CURRENTLY HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE AN OFFER
SOBER LIVING AS A CHOICE AND
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WOULD NO
LONGER HAVE SOBER LIVING AS A
CHOICE.
WHAT WAS THE UNIVERSE WERE
TALKING HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS?
WE HAVE AN IDEA -- WE HAD A NO
SO -- ACTUALLY WE WE COULD HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT A MEMBER OF UP
HERE BUT I THINK ROUGHLY OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD.
THEIR TREATMENT PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE A HOUSING ELEMENT -- SERVE
ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND PAROLEES
SO -- WHAT'S THE QUICK MATH ON
THAT LIKE SIX OR FIVE OR SIX
THOUSAND PAROLEES PER YEAR COULD
BE IMPACTED I MEAN IT WOULD BE
SOME SUBSET OF THAT BECAUSE THEY
COULD STILL PROVIDE TREATMENT
SERVICES.
AND HOUSING IT'S JUST THAT WOULD
BE HAVE TO BE DONE IN A
DIFFERENT FASHION THAT HOUSING
WOULD HAVE TO BE EXTENDED.
SO THEN YOU'RE DO YOU HAVE TO
ACTUALLY INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
SLOTS PROBABLY TO PROVIDE THE
SAME LEVEL OF PROGRAM SO I JUST
WANNA CONFIRM HE SAID ABOUT.
FIVE OR SIX THOUSAND YES THERE'S
ABSOLUTE HERE.
A YEAR SO TALK ABOUT FIVE OR SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE A YEAR INSTEAD
OF FORTY MILLION PEOPLE.
THE LEGISLATURE SAID
RESOUNDINGLY.
WE WANT TO CRIMINALIZE A LOT OF
THINGS DRUGS AND OR ALCOHOL THE
HARDEST THINGS TO GET OFF OF NO
MATTER IF YOU'VE GOT A CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND I USE JOE BLOW.
IT IS TOUGH SPECIAL ALCOHOLISM
BUT THE EFFECT OF THE DRUG
PROBLEM IT IS HARD TO KICK THE
STATE DOES NOT OFFER ENOUGH
PROGRAMS.
IN THE LEGISLATURE'S IS ETHICAL
BILLION IS FOR FOLKS TO GET
THEMSELVES PLAYING THAT'S A HARD
THING TO DO.
WE NEED THE RESOURCES.
WE DON'T WANT FOLKS IN STATE
PRISON LEGISLATURE WE UP HERE
SAID THAT WE VOTE ON THOSE BILLS.
SO AT SOME POINT IS WATER COMING
BACK OUT IF YOU WANT TO HAVE A
DEGREE OF SUCCESS.
THIS IS THE INTEGRAL PART IN
STARTING THAT SO.
AG SAID IT'S IT'S FIVE OR SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE PER YEAR.
OUT OF THE STATE OF FORTY
MILLION SO.
HOPEFULLY THE PEOPLE GET.
IT TOGETHER AND WE SEE THAT YOU
MAY NEED OR THEY DON'T COME BACK.
SO FOR ME IT'S IT'S KIND OF A A
SMALL PRICE TO PAY.
WHERE WERE HELPING WITH THAT
LIKE I SAID IF YOU LOOK BACK THE
LAWS HAVE BEEN PASSED?
THE NO ONE ELSE IN PRISON THE
JAILS AND I WANT TO PASS ANY
LAWS THE LEGISLATURE WAS
SPEAKING.
THAT -- ENHANCED PENALTIES OR
SINCE ANYBODY BACK [inaudible]
TO PRISON [inaudible]
SO.
IT'S IN ALL OF THESE FOLKS ARE
SOME OF OUR MOST AT RISK.
AND THEY HAVE A HIGH CHANCE OF
RE OFFENDING SO I WOULD SAY ON
THE WRIST KILL FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
THEY'RE PROBABLY HIGHER THAN
SOMEONE THAT'S JUST STRAIGHT
HOMELESSNESS.
SO I THINK THAT THE RISK TO THE
PUBLIC.
IS GREATLY.
INCREASE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
LIVING IN THE PROPER TREATMENT.
I THINK THIS LEGAL LONG WAY IN
AND GETTING THEM BACK ON THE
RIGHT PATH SO THIS IS SOMETHING
GET BEHIND.
AND SUPPORT -- AND OVERALL
VOTING ON THIS WILL HOLD OPEN
TODAY -- BUT YOU GOTTA TAKE A
REALLY DEEP LOOK AT INSIDE IN A
LIQUID LEGISLATURE'S MAN IS BAD
I'VE BEEN HERE FIVE YEARS.
AND THAT'S BEEN THE MANDATE.
SO WE CAN HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
I THINK THE ONE THING THAT IF
YOU WOULD -- GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY WE DO A LOT
OF WORK WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED I THINK
ONE OF THE REASONS I WANTED TO
BE HERE TODAY AND WHY IT WAS SO
VOCAL ON THE COUNCIL.
IS THAT IT'S INDIVIDUALS
THEMSELVES WHO ARE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED WHO CAME TO US AND
SAID WE WANT THE CHOICE OF SOBER
LIVING WE WANT THAT CHOICE --
AND I JUST DON'T WANT AND I
DON'T THINK IT WAS THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO POTENTIALLY.
INADVERTENTLY OR UNINTENTIONALLY
TAKE THAT OPTION AWAY FROM
PEOPLE -- AND I KNOW THAT IF IF
THERE WERE OTHER INDIVIDUALS
HERE TODAY WHO WERE -- FORMALLY
INCARCERATED THEY MIGHT SHARE
THEIR STORIES ABOUT HOW FOR A
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME DURING
THAT IMMEDIATE TRANSITION HOME
FROM PRISON.
THAT BEING ABLE -- TO BE IN A
SOBER ENVIRONMENT WAS REALLY
CRITICAL TO THEIR REINTEGRATION
AND THEIR RE ENTRY [inaudible]
THE IF I COULD JUST ASK A
QUESTION ON THIS POINT SO I GET
THAT THERE ARE SOME INDIVIDUALS
THAT WANT TO LIVE IN SEVERAL
LIVING FACILITIES BUT YOU'RE
DEFINING RECOVERY HOUSING.
AS SOBER LIVING FACILITIES ARE
NOT GIVEN AN OPTION INDIVIDUALS
WERE STRUGGLING.
WITH ADDICTIONS WHO DON'T WANT
TO BE ON THE STREET TO HAVE THAT
OPTION AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT HERE.
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND THE
SECOND PART OF THE QUESTION WHAT
THE THE THE WAY YOU THE WAY THE
WAY THE LANGUAGES DEFINING
RECOVERY HOUSING IT ONLY
INCLUDES.
SEVERAL LIVING FACILITIES AND
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE HOUSING IN
AN ABSTINENCE FOCUSED IN PEER
SUPPORT  COMMUNITY SO THERE IS
NO OTHER POSSIBILITY OF OTHER
TYPES OF FACILITIES. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE STRUGGLING.
AS YOU SAID THERE MIGHT BE SOME
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO CHOOSE
TO BE IN A SOBER LIVING
FACILITIES BUT OTHERS WHO ARE
DEALING WITH ADDICTIONS HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE -- TO TO TO WIN
THEMSELVES OFF THOSE ADDICTIONS
AND I FEEL.
IF IF THE ALTERNATIVE IS THE
STREETS THAT'S WHAT I'M THAT'S
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE DEFINITION OF RECOVERY
HOUSING ACTUALLY IS THE HIGH
DEFINITION -- THAT IT THAT SORT
OF THE TERM OF ART THAT HUD IS
USING NOW IT INCLUDES SOBER
LIVING FACILITIES AND OTHER
KINDS OF SUPPORTED SOBER LIVING
ENVIRONMENTS -- I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT IT IS NOT OUR
GOAL. TO PRECLUDE ANYONE FROM
SEEKING OTHER KINDS OF TREATMENT --
THAT'S ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
WE HAVE AS A REQUIREMENT THAT
PARTICIPATION BE VOLUNTARY.
AND THAT IF SOMEONE DECIDES THEY
NO LONGER WANT TO REMAIN IN A
SOBER LIVING ENVIRONMENT THAT
THEY'RE ASSISTED IN FINDING
OTHER KINDS OF HOUSING --
INCLUDING HOUSING THAT IS HARM
REDUCTION BASED WHICH DOES NOT
REQUIRE SOBRIETY IS A CONDITION
OF RESIDENTS SO I AGREE WITH YOU.
I I I I I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT THE RECOVERY HOUSING
DEFINITION BEING A FEDERALLY
DEFINED TERM BUT I'M LOOKING AT
THE TERM IT'S IS DEFINED HERE
AND IT JUST.
DOESN'T IT JUST STRIKES ME YOUR
YOU'RE STRIPPING OUT THE HOUSING
FIRST.
REQUIREMENTS AND AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M CONSERVE ALSO WANTED TO SAY
THE CONCERNS REMAIN HAPPY TO
CONTINUE ENGAGE WITH YOU
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SELL THIS MATTER HERE.
YEAH I THINK WE WOULD YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS IF
POSSIBLE -- I THINK THAT.
IT'S A TREATMENT CHOICE OPTION
THAT ISN'T POSSIBLE WITH THE
CURRENT STATUTORY STRUCTURE AND
WE'D LIKE TO GET SOME AGREEMENT
THERE I THINK THERE'S ALSO -- AN
UNANTICIPATED.
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON CBC ARE
THAT WE'RE NOT READY TO ADDRESS --
IF THIS LANGUAGES AND PASS AND
SO WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO BE -- I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY KEEP
THOSE CONVERSATIONS GOING.
WELL OF THE CIVIL WAR THING I
THINK ALSO WE DON'T THAT
POPULATION OUT ON THE STREET.
A LIST OF THESE WE HAVE THEM
SOMEWHERE THERE'S THERE'S SOME
TYPE OF THE GETTING HELP WITH
WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL IT.
BUT BEING OUT MYSTERY THE TONE
DEVICES THAT DOESN'T DO.
ANYBODY ANY GOOD.
THEMSELVES OF THE PUBLIC -- AT
THIS POINT THERE'S NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE A
LOT OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM.
OKAY I WILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT
SOARING HOME THIS ITEM OPEN.
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH